so i woke up this morning and i realized
that there's a lot going on in my head
that i haven't really shared with
anyone really britney spears speaking
out and on her own terms i'm here
honestly just to
open myself to others and try to shed a
light on if anyone out there has ever
gone through hardships or whatever it is
just to
put a light on it and so that person
doesn't feel
alone
because
i really know what that feels like the
singer shared a 22-minute voice memo on
youtube making a series of confessions
including how she lost her faith while
fighting to get out of her 13-year
conservatorship which her father jamie
controlled the main thing i to this day
i kind of stopped believing in god at
that time because
i didn't know how they could have 40
people leave my house a day and me work
from 8 to 6 at night
be seen changed every time i changed in
the shower
no privacy no door
nothing
how did they get away with it and what
the [ __ ] did i do to deserve that jamie
had no comment about britney's latest
claims which also include the pop
princess questioning why her mom lin and
sister jamie lynn never stepped in to
help the whole thing that made it really
confusing for me is these people are on
the street fighting for me but my sister
and my mother
aren't doing anything um to me it was
like they secretly honestly liked me
being the bad one like i was messed up
and they kind of just liked it that way
otherwise why weren't they outside my
doorstep saying baby girl get in the car
let's go
i think that's the main thing that hurt
me
um
i couldn't process how my family went
along with it for so long lynn was quick
to fire back at brittany's claims
posting this black and white image of
her daughter to instagram she writes i
have tried my best to support your
dreams and wishes and also i have tried
my best to help you out of hardships i
have never and will never turn my back
on you your rejections to the countless
times i have flown out and calls make me
feel hopeless i have tried everything i
love you so much but this talk is for
you and me only eye to eye in private i
want her to just remember back when she
was the happiest she could be
and be that person again
that's what i meant by that
and she's she's gonna get there she's
almost there now you know
there's a few little rough spots here
and there but
they can easily be ironed out she also
begs brittany to have a one-on-one
conversation instead of airing out the
family drama online as for jamie lynn
she told et earlier this year she had
nothing but support for her sister i
think that ending the conservatorship is
what my sister wanted so that's what
happened and i support that i never had
any involvement with it i just simply
wanted to be a good sister and i really
since since i was a very little girl
i've just
wanted my family to be a family and um
i want what's best for everyone and so i
think that that's all i can ever ask for
in this family that is mine in the sense
deleted post brittany also explains why
she recorded a voice note instead of
sitting down for a tell-all interview
i've had tons of opportunities oprah
interviews um
to go on a platform and and share
um hardships and or or just really
anything that's going on in my mind and
i really don't think any of that is
relevant
to um getting paid to tell your story i
feel like it's kind of silly for the
record et has learned oprah does not pay
for interviews but brittany is
reportedly being paid to talk in a
memoir my main thing is to enjoy life
and take today take one day at a time
and i try to live by that back in
february the pop star reportedly signed
a 15 million tell-all book deal and for
brit she says she's no longer fearful of
opening up about what she's been through
i've always been scared of the judgment
and definitely the embarrassment of just
of the whole thing period and the
skepticism and the cynical people of
what
um and their opinions of what
people would actually think i do think
i'm in a place now where i'm a little
bit more confident that i can be willing
to share openly
and
my thoughts and and what i've been
through
[Music]